we'll jump into this next story so we
have this from TMZ everybody's dying to
talk about the Demar Hamlin conspiracy I
woke up hearing all this crazy news
about you know whatever and then I saw
this Demar Hamlin conspiracy theory and
I said this is the most interesting
thing I've read all day or it was in the
morning so it's like the most
interesting thing I've read the past day
so Demar Hamlin has a heart attack okay
I'm sorry he didn't about it Cardiac
Arrest he didn't have a myocardial
infarction on the field he tackles a guy
takes a hit they say what is a commotion
Cardis is that what they call it
and uh now they're just saying Cardiac
Arrest they're not saying commercial
card is for whatever reason
he goes to the hospital they say you
know he's going to make it he's fine
they post a picture of him doing a
little heart they say there he is in the
hospital apparently he returned
allegedly he returned but the problem is
when he returned he was wearing a mask
glasses and his hood is over his eyes
and there he is in the window you can't
see anything he's holding a heart and
they were like look he came back he
pulls up in a car wearing sunglasses
indoors a mask and a hood over his eyes
he keep his head down walks into the
room people surrounding him you can't
see his face they haven't been like the
shielded golf cart when he's like mobile
they bring him into a room where they
film him from behind wearing a hood
waving his arms and cheering and then
the reporter's like there it is there he
is and I'm like bro I don't know who
that is well and they show calling odds
Bill Clinton they show close-ups of his
mom and his brother who are walking on
the field but we never see him right
like it's so sketchy here's the best
part about it TMZ says it's not true we
called them and asked them and they said
it was him that proves it I love that
logic it's like okay hold on I didn't
see his face you can't see his face
right yeah I think that's like that's
their best picture to prove that he was
there I think that was uh Dave Chappelle
so what do you think's going on there
like if you had to bet everything would
you say that was him or wasn't him if he
had to bet everything and not him
interesting I think I think maybe like
you know after he experiences that hit
he goes to the hospital like maybe he
doesn't look so good maybe he doesn't
want people to see like him in a
disheveled State I I have no idea but he
could be like pale sweaty gaunt and
looking miserable and so that's fair
point I mean I I don't see any incentive
for his family to to lie about his
attendance there like for for what he's
not playing games anymore he's not in
the eye of the public his cue writing
whatever you want to call it not that it
was like particularly High to begin with
but it exists right so this is basically
like what's your level of popularity
among the public he's out he's injured
he's done this is on your career I know
skateboarders who are on the verge of
turning pro and they sprain their ankle
knock him out for three months and they
get dropped by every company so here's a
guy who is knocked out of the press no
one's talking about him they're like we
need to get him back out there and I can
certainly imagine an agent coming in and
being like look man I know you're hurt
but we gotta get you back out there and
get some cameras and get some press
attention so that you don't lose the
news cycle what can we do we can't leave
the hospital I said let's just get a guy
put a mask on sunglasses we'll do a
quick appearance we'll say it's you no
one will know it'll never prove it that
that that to me makes a lot of sense
what people think is that Demar died and
the vaccines did it I think he's dead I
think the vaccine did it they think they
run a body double which makes no sense I
don't want that to be true man
if he died from a heart attack they
would just say guys he died from a heart
attack right we all know he had a heart
attack
yeah I don't know I think he's probably
not in good shape and I think he's that
I don't think that was him it's too
weird why wouldn't you just show his
face at any point even his eyes he might
look like I don't know he's got a
hood on and a mouth you can't show his
eyes at all like they did not show this
person like Islam stuff sure it's better
than nothing right I can't he shows up
in the cup what gets me is like they
brought his mom and younger brother
who's like a little kid out like it is
weird like yeah with him I don't have an
opinion on whether it is or is not him
but it is super weird to be like we
can't come up with any clear pictures
that actually identify this as the guy
we're saying like just take our word for
it that's super weird like they could
have just just as easily like taken a
picture of him in the booth or like in
the what whatever that's called the box
I'm super into sports as you can tell in
the box and been like oh yeah look he's
here with the head coach or the guy who
owns just whatever
he looks like crap he doesn't want that
job but still and why then why show up
why would they film in the booth from
behind of him waving his arms in the air
instead of just doing nothing but if
it's what you're saying like I do think
that's a much higher risk strategy
because if they find out it's some body
double or whatever like that would just
be disaster no no no no no that would be
huge that would be amazing this
conspiracy theory right now is press so
at the very first at the very least he
might have been thinking like yeah I'm
gonna come back and check out the game
and hang out in the box and they were
like did you shoot you do wear a mask
and sunglasses get everybody going crazy
think it's a conspiracy that is also a
possibility because I mean that seems
more plausible I would say like that one
than like the body double thing but it's
like look at this picture of him his
hood is over his eyes he's not even
looking at the at the field why is he
throwing the rock up like is he a JC fan
he's doing a heart
you see his hood is over his eyes he's
not looking at anything what is going on
he's not even looking at the field he's
like like someone told him hey stand by
the window and do a sign they're gonna
take a picture he's like okay I can't
see so I'll do it right here is this
good that makes no sense what's he he's
just an angle thing he's like looking
down like this it's over oh come on dude
his eyes are completely covered with the
hood you can see that it's not him
there's no way I'm gonna say it I'm
gonna say it's him taking a safe ride
here yeah I just don't understand why
they can't okay why they wouldn't come
up with a decent and also we're at a
casino and you walk up to the Demar
Hamlin is it him table and there's it is
and it isn't you're putting your chips
on the it's him yeah wow yeah because
that's why I asked you the question but
here's you know you know why I wouldn't
because there's no proof to suggest it
is there's no evidence his family saying
it is
um his family never said it was sorry he
walked on the field I'm a journalist he
said he said they contacted I I made a
phone call it's Bill Clinton
his family said it you heard his family
actually come out and say it happened
because all I know is that TMZ said we
made a phone call and they confirmed it
I'm like I shouldn't say that but like
I assumed from that press release they
contacted the bills or whatever team he
plays for you know then they were like
yes indeed we brought him back like they
didn't say we talked to his mom they
didn't say we talked to his uncle like
they they didn't say anything they just
said yes someone has confirmed it was
him like this is so weirdly non-specific
if it was specific and to your point
like if he felt awful if he didn't look
good like why not just be like yeah he's
not back yet but he's watching the game
from home he's having a good time like
yeah why why bring him out there if he
is in a position where he looks so
terrible he doesn't want to be seen like
you must mean that he also feels awful
and we're gonna drag him to a football
stadium like that seems cruel or
desperate or maybe he wanted to be there
I don't know here look look watch this
video I want anyone to know watch this
video looks like Jamar Hamlin is dead
watch yes if they show him in the
stadium in any capacity it will blow the
doors off of this place Demar Hamlin
just showed up and it looks like his mom
and his little brother is there oh we
love to see it stay tuned it's the
Bengals so yeah we saw no one we saw
nothing coming up on CBS also he says it
if they show him in any capacity
foreshadowing
[Applause]
he's wearing sunglasses his head is down
he's got a hood and a mask on I just why
why
and then he just go no stopping no
looking no waving nothing just Zip Zip
there's more there's more
I got it like wait a minute
telling us it was so good to have him
around he told us it's baby steps right
now
how involved he wants to be every day a
spokesperson close to the family said
despite being out of the hospital he
still has a lengthy recovery he requires
oxygen and he has his heart rate
monitored regularly but he is upbeat
he's positive yeah if he requires oxygen
he's nothing in the room do you see
oxygen there I don't right here what a
scene oh I mean why are they filming
this
why did they film him from behind in the
room waving his arms like this you can't
see his face
[Applause]
any of this by the way I'm just going
based off what you guys are talking
about my odds have suddenly shifted I
mean when he's doing
he's doing truly bad shape we need to do
that wouldn't he be winded like also why
don't you pull your hood back for God's
sake well they also just said he
requires auction I don't see oxygen yeah
exactly Somebody explain to me maybe
what's going on maybe it's like through
the clothing you have a backpack we
can't see that's scary look at his hood
over his eyes he's not looking at
anything I love this story he might as
well be wearing them
it's just weird here you can see it's
actually Kanye West but like it's Kanye
West why film this video This Way like
they film it from the side from behind
so that little kid is not his brother
unless he's a kid I don't know about
which totally possible like he's in
there alone without the people we
brought out as his mom and brother yeah
Somebody explain to me what's going on I
don't know that's the one they said
or something so this tweet this guy said
my thought is that he's no longer with
us I don't know about that because that
didn't make sense either it would make
no sense to have him come out if he
wasn't around like if he in the hospital
did you build your dad yeah yeah it
actually would make more sense they
would say it was commercial Cardis he
took a hit to the heart we tried to save
him we couldn't and having him come out
and say he's on oxygen and all this
stuff is actually like more suspect yeah
so I don't think he's dead I'm just like
I think he's really sick and that's sad
if we shouldn't like use a fake person
as a puppet to advance The Narrative of
what the Bengals like I don't have any
proof that that's not him there's no
part of me that would be in any way
surprised if I found out that that was
definitely not him like there there is
no this guy is so sick he requires
auction his mom isn't even sitting with
him in this shot like are you what they
put no effort into actually making their
own seem like these or the simulation
man everything's fake he's also wearing
bright red he is the only person they're
like please notice exactly who's walking
through the crowd right now like think
about this think about this when you
wear your Bulls the journalists have
provided no evidence spills colors that
he was actually there other than that's
what they claim and I'm like okay well
for me that's fine you can claim
whatever you want but I don't believe it
uh right like you know I need I need
something more than just be like he was
there trust me see here's a picture of a
guy in a jacket I'm like I don't know
who that guy is yeah that could be Bill
Clinton though probably not Bill Clinton
because he'll be waving his arms around
like that he's old man but that could be
anybody so if they came and said no we
got a photo even if they did that even
if they're like here's a photo of him
smiling with fans I'd be like oh okay
well you know they didn't film it but
I'll take I'll take them exactly like I
wouldn't have been surprised if he was
in the box with the owner of the team
right oh and the wife and the kids were
someone Super Chat the wife and the kid
weren't even with him when when the when
the when the brother or the mom walked
in I'm sorry the brother and the Mom
they're not with him they're walking in
different like I said like oh yeah also
your son is so sick he requires oxygen
we're bringing him to a game and like I
don't know who that little kid is but
it's definitely not his brother like
here's the thing consider this for the
media the media can come out and say and
they will
Demar Hamlin showed up he was there
regular people will hear that and be
like oh did you hear he's out of the
hospital he's there and then you'll be
like Brody to watch the video no yeah
that was that didn't look like him I
don't know the media said that it was
him so it was
that twin we don't know about maybe that
that point is if it was a twin they
would not have covered his face yeah I
don't know man maybe he doesn't look
enough like him there he's like a scar
from like a fraternal twins like they're
both boys but they don't look like at
all they're not the same size right it's
a guy whose name is DeMar Hamlin but
it's a totally different guy
he's a dentist from Dubuque did you see
that there's another Super Chat in there
that said that he posted Tim look his
Twitter he posted clone did you see that
he deposited clown he posted the word
clone apparently I can't fact check it
so if someone should look it up real
quickly but if if he posted that that
makes it even weirder I really hope uh
I really hope that's true yeah that'd be
wild Your Voice Sounds like a car idling
to me sometimes it's so low oh yeah he
did yeah yo hey come on man what what
wait what is this is that supposed to be
is that him so there's a painting of him
some dude whose face you can't see and
it says clone yeah oh this there's so
much obfuscation of his face yeah so
he's probably making fun of the idea
being like people think it's like a
clone of me or something but he's still
he's admitting that it was not him no I
think he's making fun of the idea like
this is a picture I guess I guess but
where is his oxygen yeah
well I continue to obfuscate your face
like that though too I mean he's
generating press for himself I mean why
did why did you do that you know yeah
it's a good point good point he's gen
he's generating pressure himself the
fact that we're talking about it yeah
like a mostly overtly political show
I mean it's a fun thought process I I
think this is weird but all right so I
don't know what he looks like but it the
picture if you zoom in you could and you
knew what he looked like you would be
able to identify him right I don't know
what he looks like but if you zoom in on
that and you knew like you were familiar
with what he looked like you could be
like yes that is him no that's not
like if that was someone that I knew
like if that was like James Hetfield's
face or like you know whatever Michael
Jordan's face or whatever I could
probably be like all right I I'm I'm
familiar with the shape of the eyes and
the nose if you are alive and well why
is this the photo you post at your job I
mean I I don't know that I can answer
questions like that I'm just saying that
even though that isn't the most I'm
willing to be wrong on this front I just
don't think I am you know Fair fine yeah
I mean it kind of feels like this
painting or whatever on the brick is
like in memoriam you know what I mean
hmm like when they do those paintings
they put it up you can't even see his
tattoos that's the other thing where are
these identifying markers I mean it's
winter I'm sure it's snowing but still
still it was it was actually pretty
intense in Buffalo but I don't
understand sunglasses and a snowstorm
indoors yeah
yeah it's like I don't know unless
it's oh it's snowing really rough but
then
press appearance thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time